I'll preface my question by saying that
I admire your work for a number of
different reasons and perhaps what I
find most admire about you is your
strict sense of ethnic and religious
identity as a Jew your Jew is your
Jewish background has clearly played a
significant role in influencing or
shaping the political social and
cultural ideals and values that you have
as well as your support for Israel as a
nation-state so I'm wondering then do
you support the classical definition of
a nation as being demographically and
culturally homogeneous like that of
Israel similar to the definition that
American forefathers generally upheld
with exceptions of course until the
heart seller Immigration Act of 1965
okay so one I want to correct a
mischaracterization you said that I take
a lot of pride in my ethnic and
religious identity I take no pride in my
ethnic identity I take a lot of pride in
my religious identity so there are a lot
of people who have been born Jews who I
just don't care about really like no I'm
Chomsky was born Jewish he's a schmuck
like I I don't I don't care at all
Bernie Sanders born Jewish schmuck like
I don't know
so so the point that I'm making is that
religious identity is a different thing
because that's a set of ideas and values
a religion is cradle and in the same way
the American Declaration of Independence
is cradle so when it comes to the
definition of a nation I would say that
it is very important that a nation have
a Creed in common I'm not particularly
interested in having an ethnicity in
common when they say that Israel for
example is ethnically homogeneous that's
just not true Israel is filled with
Russian Jews and Ethiopian Jews and
Yemeni Jews my wife is a Moroccan Jew so
just because they all have a religion
income and doesn't make them ethnically
identical by any stretch of the
imagination
again there's no it's it's pretty hard
to find somebody who's more ethical
ethnically non identical than a Russian
Jew and an Ethiopian Jew so the reason
that I believe in Israel is a nation
state is because it's not for ethnic
reasons it's because of religious
observance reasons that Israel is a
place where the religion of Judaism can
thrive and be safe which i think is an
important thing
I think the same thing is true in the
United States when it comes to the Creed
of the United States I think America is
a cradle country I think it's what has
made America great now that's not to say
that everybody who comes into the
country has an equal capacity to
assimilate to that cream the
assimilation capacity of people I don't
think has to do much with ethnic
identity I think it does have to do with
cultural identity I think there are
cultures that come into the country
people come from various cultures who
may not be as easily able to assimilate
because obviously that's just the case I
mean there are people who come in and
they already know English there are
people who come in and they've already
had a history with Western democracy
there are people who come in and they've
never seen a gay person before and in
their old country gay people were came
and killed so it's it's important to
recognize that cultures are not the same
thing as ethnicities and I think it's a
dangerous game to play when we say that
the that ethnicity means culture when
they clearly do not mean anything of the
sort